let's talk about the news
this is the big story
from nbc 5 dfw texas house texas house
votes to track down democrats arrest
them when they return to texas house
democrats can't be arrested until they
return to the state the governor says so
this is the update because initially
governor greg abbott was like we will
arrest them mark my words
now the texas house was like all in
favor of arresting them and they're like
yes
the democrats are going to get arrested
there's a funny thing about all this
it's a filibuster basically apparently
they the texas texas has already passed
the bill anyway the the voter bills the
media is trying to make it seem like
republicans are trying to strip away the
rights of regular people
the republicans have no real counter to
this because the mainstream media lies
all the time and conservative media
doesn't
oh i can already hear the collective
screams of all the leftists who are hate
watching this show claiming that all
conservative media does is lie
yeah then why isn't tucker crossing
coming out saying republicans are trying
to pass voter protection bills to
protect the rights of marginalized
people but the left thinks that they
should take those rights away no he
doesn't do that the right never does
that and that's one of the reasons the
left keeps taking because they keep
putting pressure they keep doing these
propaganda campaigns well at the very
least republicans say they'll arrest
these democrats who are uh what are they
their fugitives yeah apparently now
yeah well i mean i guess they're gonna
get arrested right does this mean that
they're officially arrested like does
this or not i mean does this mean like
do they have to like vote on this this
declaration that they're going to arrest
them or is it they did vote
they voted so are they on the lam now
yes oh wow
well that was why gene what's his name
was tweeting about his first meal
delicious fugitive oh it's a caesar
salad oh my gosh and you get kamala
harris and you get the national level
democrats and all of their cronies in
media who love licking their feet saying
like these are heroes helping protect
the rights of people let me explain
something very very simple to everybody
what the republicans are doing actually
is to protect the rights of
people who want to vote what the
democrats are doing are purposefully
damaging voter integrity which confuses
and mucks up the system and makes it
very difficult for people's votes to be
counted properly for for the system to
work properly there's no chain of
custody on some of these votes they have
curbside voting universal mail and
voting 24 hour voting not only that it's
gonna it's it's really expensive you
gotta maintain uh staffing for these
things and security for these things so
what the republicans are doing is
they're trying to pull back only a
little bit
of those special provisions which
effectively means the republicans are
still losing no matter what this is this
is the this is the power of the
democratic party they win no matter what
happens
if they don't get what they're asking
for right now the republicans only
curtail a little bit
of the of the advanced voting stuff that
democrats got and if the republicans
back down the democrats get indefinite
coved special voting access so
i don't know there are people who are
surprised i'm not a fan of the dem of
the of the republican party at this
point granted it's texas my mind
consistently goes to the military
industrial complex the liberal economic
order developed 1946.
it's basically of the party of the
warmonger i mean i thought of those
neocons growing up in the early 2000s
and now
it's just accepting that this group like
bill crystal and like
i don't know dick dick cheney's not
really involved with the democratic
lincoln project is that what it is no
just like those creepy weirdos friends
with raytheon and now they're they got
their tentacles inside the brains of the
dnc
i mean they always did
yeah so it's it's funny when people talk
about what the democrats are doing and
i'm like yo the democrats and the
republicans are doing all of that
forever the only thing that changed was
that donald trump ran full speed and
slammed his body into the front doors
and broke him down
and then with trump throwing himself the
doors and getting in people believe the
republican party somehow like
was better
they're not i just saw um
an article that said that the dnc is
proposing that they're gonna go through
people's text messages to look for well
that's that's information i mean that's
that's that's that's absolute disgusting
overreach of power oh that's no that's
that's beyonce this is this is this is
it the democrats are like communist
authoritarians at this point but do you
really believe they haven't been doing
that this whole time good point they're
just announcing it now but no no no
they're going to block your texts like
that's something i've never i've never
seen yeah that no that is on a whole
other level unless you live in cuba
blocking your phone call like if you
just couldn't make a phone call because
your last phone call you said some stuff
in it redacted well definitely we should
get into that but let's talk about
what's going on in texas we got the
story from nbc they say with only 80 of
150 house members present tuesday the
house lacks the necessary two-thirds of
legislators to do business a call of the
house motion was called that compels all
members to the house to appear in the
chamber those who do not appear are
subject to arrest the call the house was
approved 76-4
with four democrats in the house chamber
voting nay following the vote the doors
to the house chamber were locked
preventing anyone else from coming or
going wow
yeah this is no joke state troopers in
the texas department of safety may now
be appointed to go look for the missing
legislators at their respective
businesses and homes
but they'll be unlikely to find any of
them since they left the state the day
before texas law enforcement is unlikely
to attract the lawmakers to dc since
they lack jurisdiction the nation's
capital during an interview on fox news
monday night governor greg abbott said
once the democrats who fled the state
return to texas they will be arrested
and brought back to the capitol they're
quitters that's not the way we do things
abbott said in the television interview
this is fascinating why the democrats
are claiming to get rid of the
filibuster the filibuster is a problem
they say at the federal level
but this is basically what they're doing
you can chart a plane and flee you can
be you could pick up a fugitive and flee
your actual duty in texas
and i mean this is worse than a
filibuster
it's like miles it's it's a
yeah it's a hardcore filibuster for sure
like uh so the way the filibuster
basically works in uh in in the senate
if someone says hey i filibuster then
they need 60 votes to overcome the
filibuster i guess they did that because
they didn't like the idea of someone
standing up and talking for 30 hours
which just shut downs the vote like it
ends the session and so i guess the
democrats tried things like that you
know trying to they they've delayed the
vote they've skipped that on the vote
and they keep doing this because they've
lost texas now here's here's the problem
man
you can't function this way we can't how
is texas how is any state how is the
government supposed to function when
people are just like if i don't get what
i want to quit
i'll walk out so is this uh so is this
come from like the oregon republicans
doing this to like fight against
whatever it was there like it was
climate change like climate change thing
did they set the precedent here and this
is just the democrats that are carrying
it on no i think this is just a normal
tactic but
it's interesting you see this and and
the core issue here is voting like we're
not even talking about policy anymore
this is literally just i hate you and
you hate me and let's hate each other as
much as possible if they were like you
know we need a bill that like fixes the
road the democrats are alike but you're
not going to fix the roads right we
argue over policy like that makes sense
now they're just like the democrats are
like we want no security in our election
we want people to just get a ballot sent
to a random house and if you disagree
you're a racist oh yeah yeah so that
narrative didn't work if these people
these these democratic politicians that
fled if they're doing like what their
conscience dictates then i guess they're
doing the right thing for them but
should then they be removed from office
because they can't functionally
participate ethically
but how do they actually think they're
doing the right thing i think it's a
very signal i don't think they genuinely
believe that they're saving the day
i i mean let's be real
yeah it's it's it's campaigning their
constituents and their blue areas are
going to be like yay clapping and
cheering for it nothing's going to
change nothing's going to get done
they're what are they going to do stay
this someone's saying what do they do
stay out of texas for a year i don't
know because abbott said we will keep
calling special sessions
until the election we'll keep doing it
so that means the democrats from texas
have to have fled the state and they
can't return
what's a special uh what do you call it
a special what a special session what's
that do they say election a special
session
so the way it works is there's no
there's the normal process by which
there's a session of the of the house
like most states and jurisdictions have
this
and
if
the governor chooses he can convene a
special session and call back the the
state senate and the state
representatives to come in and do their
votes and everything so a lot of states
have that system so governor greg abbott
the republicans republicans have texas
so he said okay special session it is
and then the democrats were like no and
they ran away now there's no quorum now
they can't hold the vote so why don't
they just treat it as abstentions
that's a good point and i think they
should i think i think they they i was
saying earlier they should have they
should vote on this bill right now they
should put it somewhere to draft it up
if you are absent
you know for for uh
at least
three sessions in a row
you forfeit your position as a
representative from your district and
you are removed or something like that
yeah you start abstaining if you maybe
maybe you could have someone come in and
vote for you
maybe at the very least send a proxy but
then
why are they getting taxpayer money
yeah imagine imagine imagine you're
you're a taxpayer in texas
and these people are like we're getting
paid and they're going to party on
private jets yeah yeah and their
salaries should probably be
halted while they're
while they're refusing to do their job
good point yeah look i'm all for the
civil disobedience right but hey that
has consequences well you get arrested
you get fined you get all that stuff
where in the private sector would you be
able to say i'm just not coming into
work and not only that i'm not coming
until you give me what you want what i
want it sounds like and you have to
still pay me
pay me nowadays actually a lot of places
in the world okay well i'm old-fashioned
i guess
yeah people do this all the time where
they'll be like i've decided that you're
a bigot so i'm not coming to work for
two weeks the boss goes okay okay wow
whatever you say diversity training oh
my gosh yeah there was uh uh one of the
companies i worked at who i won't name
for this one's a bit specific there was
a woman who threatened retaliation
against anybody who who told her she had
to work and so apparently she literally
did no work and she got paid a ton of
money but what was the reason
every all the bosses were scared that
they would get a harassment complaint
and they were like
but she was saying they were sexist or
harassing her or what yeah
okay like i don't think it was as overt
like she walked in and said i will say
this about you
but apparently upper management was
scared that they knew this woman would
do it and it was implied so they were
just like here's your salary you can
have whatever you want what do whatever
you want have a nice day and she's got
paid to do nothing female privilege and
i remember talking to one staff and they
were like this person literally doesn't
work here but it's here just eats food
and then gets paid and then leaves and
then i was like so why why are they
paying this person and they're like
because she threatens them you know
they're they're scared so that's like
implied blackmail
which apparently is not a crime you can
if you if you're subtle enough about it
you can get away with it no ian it's not
blackmail to say i will report you for
harassment
right you're just doing your job
doing the right thing at that point yes
even if they're not harassing can i say
that i will
report you for harassment
in parentheses would say if you actually
harassed me but you didn't the line is
very thin and it really just depends on
whether or not the feds want to go after
you or the authorities whatever in the
state
but if you threaten
somebody with accusing them of a crime
it could be extortion or blackmail
but depending on how you frame it
then they can't accuse the person of you
know
so the issue is if you're an employee
then in this instance you don't actually
demand anything
you just say i've had it up to here with
this harassment and you look around they
say i'm not going to that person so you
get a person who just anyway the
democrats
this is my problem with the democrats is
the dnc
is obviously corrupt since since i've
seen what they did to bernie sanders in
2016 and probably so many other things
you see this the dnc stuff
but that doesn't mean that every
democrat is culpable corrupt or even has
bad intentions like there's some amazing
people that that happened to be in the
democratic party like obviously tulsi
gabbard i think she was incredible is
she still there though no she wrote
i think i think it mostly does
i do
the republican party today is very very
different like trump came in and smashed
through those doors yeah you had the
neocons a lot of those people fled to
the democratic party all right but i'll
put it this way if like you know look
man i know i know the cartels murder
tons and tons of people doesn't mean
every cartel member is a bad person
right well that's actually a good point
no no no no i don't think
some people are drafted into that
lifestyle kind of against their will and
they don't want to do the damage and
they're kind of forced to
get out
that's a good that's a good point but i
was making i was being facetious a
little bit the democratic party is not a
a cult of well well actually okay all
right okay well the democratic party is
bad but you can always walk away
you choose to be a democrat you know
as far as i know democrats aren't going
to hunt you down for being an apostate
to the democratic party
but uh
i think the democratic party it's really
fascinating to see this meme where
people say
that the left and the right both view
each other as the problem i saw someone
said the left thinks the right is
abusing its power and we'll do we'll
stop at nothing and the right thinks the
left is doing it and people need to
realize it's like
hold on a minute the people who say that
are the people who are like sitting back
with their feet up watching police
academy on rerun like like on repeat not
really paying attention what's going on
looking at the screen and seeing
liberals and conservatives fighting and
going they just think each other are bad
well it's true they do but one side's
objectively right and one side's
objectively wrong and the democrats are
psychopaths the republicans are do
nothings the democrats are inside what
they did to bernie was basically like
made an apostate out of him it seemed
like in 2016. he just bent over and took
he just let them just take it too it's a
disappointment yeah man why didn't he
run independent i'm scared for my whole
life i'll be wondering 2016. he could
have went independent and won that race
he just sold out he's just a sellout
that's it
how many houses does bernie sanders have
three i think it's three three three
yeah one that's worth over 1.2 million
or something oh really i don't know i'm
guessing with inflation maybe
i think he's got like a townhouse in dc
for work he's got his house in vermont
and he's got a summer home he has wife's
parents you write a book you can be a
millionaire too that's right you write a
book so so where did bernie go when when
the democrats started going crazy and
demanding allegiance and bernie i
remember that photo of bernie in the gym
with that with that really crappy banner
he's like i'm running for president and
then he runs he gets really really
popular because people saw him as a
populist
and he was
and then uh he had a meeting with the
dnc and he was like okay i'll do
whatever you say hillary clinton
and then he endorsed her
yeah yeah the democratic machine is
broken
the neocon republicans fled to the
democrats and now they're panicking
because the there's like the the the
gates
to you know it reminds me of that
battling lord of the rings while the
orcs are trying to break into what is it
yeah yeah that's what it is and uh it's
probably a bad analogy because in this
instance the the orcs are the good guys
breaking down the door but the point is
the democrats are in the in the fortress
and they've they've crossed the bridge
the they've they've broken the doors
down and now the elites are freaking out
because with a lot of the populist
republicans and trump's popularity they
can't do anything about it now steve
bannon made a good point or no actually
i don't think it was steve bannon but uh
i can't remember who it was that
populism only goes so far was it was
this their abilities uh maybe no that
was daryl it was darren yeah yeah
populism only gets you so much you can
have all the people on your side but if
you don't have any of the the elite
factions you struggle to get anything
done true thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you